al menos 23 personas resultaron heridas
10 de ellas con arma de fuego en una
estación del metro de brooklyn de
acuerdo con las fuerzas de seguridad se
encontraron varios dispositivos sin
detonar el sospechoso continúa prófugo
el presidente de méxico andrés manuel
lópez obrador ofreció su mensaje de los
100 primeros días de cada año
anb lo reconoció el impacto del cob y 19
y la importancia de la recuperación
económica insistió asimismo en la
importancia de legislar en contra de la
privatización eléctrica ampliamos desde
ciudad de mexico
el presidente joe biden acusó a vladimir
putin de cometer genocidio eeuu reino
unido y australia comenzaron a
investigar el uso de armas químicas en
mariupol que denunció sin pruebas el
mandatario ucraniano volodymyr selenski
putin niega los hechos y calificó de
falsificación las denuncias
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo serán hoy es un
gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en nueva
york donde las autoridades se elevaron a
23 la cifra de heridos por el tiroteo en
el metro de brooklyn y anunciaron que el
sospechoso fue identificado como frank
james de 62 años el ataque dejó 23
personas heridas 10 de ellas por arma de
fuego
el resto ingresaron al hospital por
inhalación de humo la policía de nueva
york dijo que logró recuperar una
pistola y varios cargadores en la escena
la policía dijo también que el tirador
disparó al menos 33 veces y el fbi
anunció que su fuerza de tarea conjunta
contra el terrorismo está participando
en la investigación
no tenemos a nadie en custodia en este
momento estamos buscando a frank james
sabemos que el resto estaban de lujo las
llaves de desa van de lujo fueron
halladas en la escena del crimen en el
tren subterráneo y el señor james hizo
esas publicaciones en redes sociales
estamos analizando eso pero si es
correcto
basados en información preliminar hay
algunas publicaciones que posiblemente
se relacionen a la persona interés que
estamos buscando donde él menciona falta
de vivienda menciona nueva york y
también menciona el alcalde adams y como
resultado de eso estamos tomando medidas
preventivas para conocer más detalles
sobre este suceso que ocurre en medio de
un aumento generalizado de la violencia
de nueva york- desde el inicio de la
pandemia veamos el siguiente informe de
gabriel colchón en plena hora pico un
hombre disparó contra los pasajeros del
metro de nueva york después de haber
arrojado un gas en el vagón el ataque
provocó escenas de caos en brooklyn
había mucha gente salir de la estación
de tren gritando pidiendo ayuda vi a una
señora que recibió un disparo en la
pierna una de las señoras dijo que era
un tipo con una pistola y que tenía una
máscara y un chaleco y estaba disparando
a la gente vas
los pasajeros bajaron del tren en estado
de confusión
al principio fue un momento de shock
estaba con algunos amigos no sabía qué
iba a pasar tenía miedo no sabía qué
hacer no lo sabía me bajé el tren me que
junto a unos policías y espere lo mejor
eso es todo
nueva york- ha visto un aumento en la
tasa de criminalidad desde el inicio de
la pandemia tan solo en lo ocurrido de
2022 la ciudad ha registrado
260 tiroteos
la gente de todo el estado de nueva york
está con la gente de esta ciudad de esta
comunidad y decimos no más no más
tiroteos masivos no más alteraciones de
la vida no estamos creando angustia para
la gente que solo trata de vivir sus
vidas como neoyorquinos normales eso
tiene que terminar y terminar ahora ya
el ataque tuvo lugar un día después que
el presidente joe biden anunciara nuevas
medidas para controlar el porte de armas
de fuego en el país específicamente
contra las de fabricación casera
conocidas como armas fantasma la medida
que enfrenta la oposición el poderoso
lobby armamentístico
seguimos en eeuu donde el debate sobre
los derechos reproductivos de las
mujeres vuelve a estar sobre la mesa
después de que este martes el estado de
oklahoma diera luz verde a la medida más
restrictiva sobre el aborto aprobada en
el país
de este modo oklahoma se suma a texas en
la defensa de los derechos pro-vida
mientras los estados demócratas
continúan defendiendo el derecho al
aborto marta moya tiene más información
oklahoma es desde este martes el estado
más restrictivo con el aborto en eeuu el
gobernador republicano kevin state firmó
la ley que prohíbe este derecho en todas
las causales excepto cuando la vida de
la madre está en riesgo
webber mouse robar queremos que oklahoma
sea el estado más prohibida del país
queremos prohibir el aborto en nuestro
equipo como el fiscal general y yo
sabemos que este proyecto de ley será
desafiado por activistas liberales de la
costa que siempre parecen querer venir a
dictar un mandato y desafiar nuestra
forma de vida
observar como la nueva legislación de
oklahoma castiga con hasta 10 años de
prisión que un médico realiza un aborto
a una mujer en cualquier momento de la
gestación está restrictiva medida se
suma a las del estado sureño de texas
que en mayo de 2021 también impulsó una
ley para prohibir la interrupción del
embarazo después de la sexta semana de
gestación allí el domingo 10 de abril un
fiscal desestimó la acusación de
asesinato que la justicia había imputado
a la hispana lissl herrera por
presuntamente inducir se un aborto una
polémica decisión que pone en entredicho
tenemos de la aplicación de esta ley
gisela herrera fue acusada por un aborto
auto inducido en virtud de la ley de
homicidios de texas el verdadero
problema es que el estatuto de homicidio
de ese estado excluye expresamente la
muerte de un niño no nacido y
criminaliza la conducta de la madre del
niño no nacido así que el estatuto de
homicidio simplemente no se aplica en
base a los derechos que conocemos
a pocos meses de las elecciones de mitad
de mandato del partido republicano y sus
gobernantes estatales impulsan medidas
conservadoras en materia de derechos
como el aborto la inmigración al tiempo
que los estados más progresistas los
blindan y los defienden desde las
instituciones y desde las calles
seguimos en el continente porque el
presidente de méxico andrés manuel lópez
obrador ofreció su mensaje de los 100
primeros días de cada año esta vez el
discurso llega después de que lograra la
victoria en el referendo revocatorio que
él mismo convocó en su contra y que sólo
contó con una participación del 17 por
ciento del padrón electoral
anteriormente nuestro corresponsal en
méxico mario carbón nos contaba que dijo
lópez obrador en su discurso
hola el presidente destacó dos objetivos
fundamentales para lo que le resta de su
gobierno uno es lograr la soberanía
energética y otra la soberanía
alimentaria el tema de la soberanía
energética dijo que pues consiste en
aumentar la producción de crudo y
también se ha reducido en 48 por ciento
dijo el año pasado la importación
esto gracias a la rehabilitación de las
refinerías en este tema destacó algo muy
importante que es la próxima discusión
de la reforma eléctrica en la cámara de
diputados el próximo domingo en donde
dijo son tiempos de definiciones y se
verá si los diputados están por los
intereses particulares de las empresas y
gobiernos extranjeros o por el beneficio
del pueblo dijo que si no logran la
mayoría de votos y enviará una
iniciativa al día siguiente para
proteger el litio y garantizar que el
litio sea de uso exclusivo de la nación
asimismo en la soberanía alimentaria
destacó que se aumentará la producción
de alimentos básicos se aumentará en 2
millones de toneladas la producción de
granos como maíz y también frijol habló
también de seguridad dijo que se ha
logrado la reducción de 9 de 12 delitos
de alto impacto no así en tres y destacó
sin duda el aumento de 15 por ciento en
feminicidios en francia sigue la campaña
electoral ahora en pugna de dos
candidatos de cara a la segunda
presidencial del 24 de abril manuel
macrón viajó a la región gran este
tierras históricamente favorables a la
extrema derecha macrón se centró durante
este viaje en temas de salud seguridad y
europa nuestra periodista natalia ruiz
tiene más detalles
ir al encuentro de los franceses esa es
la estrategia de campaña de manuel marco
antes de la segunda vuelta de la
elección presidencial
este día martes comenzó aquí en miluce
esta es la región del gran este quizás
la región más afectada por la pandemia
de kobe en 2020 aquí el presidente
candidato se reunió con personal
sanitario con quien discutió sobre la
falta de recursos en los hospitales pero
de hecho a su llegada varias personas lo
esperaban y le hicieron preguntas le
hicieron reclamos ante ellos emanuel
marco defendió su gestión denos los
medios de poder para curar a los
pacientes
- los medios habrá más camas la gente
sufre habrá más camas señor macros
mejoren nuestras condiciones mejoren
nuestras condiciones de trabajo e
invertimos en los hospitales pusimos 19
mil millones en total porque la
condición no eran buenas ahora lo que
hay que hacer es cambiar la organización
en esta región bastión de marie le pen
como lo muestran los resultados de la
primera vuelta macro no cambia de tono y
no duda en atacar a su adversaria
directamente tenemos una cantidad
compartido que es pueblo potencia en
cartón nunca se van a ver sus oponentes
van a la provincia sólo para reunirse
con quienes los apoyan hacen conferencia
de prensa en hoteles nunca van a ver a
la gente que no está de acuerdo con
ellos jamás
este día maratónico de gira de manuel
más como por la región del gran este
término aquí en estrasburgo quizás hay
un lugar más simbólicos de europa que
esté aquí donde hay varias instituciones
europeas entre ellas el parlamento
europeo aquí entre los cientos de
presentes con banderas de europa con
banderas de francia pero también con
banderas de ucrania de mano el mayor
recordó la importancia del proyecto
europeo y aseguró que en caso de una
victoria de marina europea en el próximo
24 de abril pues ella seguirá por esa
línea que siempre ha tenido en mente que
es la de desmantelar el bloque europeo
entretanto marín lepe en la candidata de
extrema derecha continuó con su campaña
en la población de vernon al norte del
país desde allí la aspirante descargó
una ola de críticas contra las
propuestas de su contrincante enmanuel
macrón como la de suavizar su postura
sobre la polémica reforma de pensiones y
el aumento de la edad de jubilación de
penn también cuestionó la forma en que
el mandatario ha abordado varias de las
crisis que se han presentado durante su
gobierno
en el día 48 de la invasión rusa y
ucrania las tropas del kremlim han
intensificado su campaña en la ciudad
portuaria de mariupol según las
autoridades ucranianas al menos 20.000
personas podrían haber muerto en la
estratégica ciudad mientras que las
autoridades de eeuu reino unido y
australia investigan las denuncias sin
verificar de uso de armas químicas por
parte del ejército ruso el presidente
joe biden dijo que se trata de un
genocidio
estoy haciendo todo lo que esté a mi
alcance mediante órdenes ejecutivas para
bajar los costos y hacer frente al
precio de putin
ninguno de nosotros debería depender de
que un dictador declare la guerra y
cometa un genocidio a medio mundo de
distancia entre tanto vladimir putin
también dijo que las acusaciones de un
asesinato de civiles en muchas son la
misma falsificación que las de armas
químicas en siria y aseguró que
occidente no podrá aislar a su país el
mandatario afirmó no tener dudas de que
alcanzará todos sus objetivos en ucrania
que son según sus palabras claros y
nobles las palabras de putin llegaron
durante la conmemoración del día de la
cosmonáutica rusa hace 41 años el
cosmonauta soviético yuri gagarín fue el
primer hombre en viajar al espacio el
presidente de belarús y aliado político
de putin alexander lukashenko estuvo
presente en el acto y acordó proyectos
conjuntos en materia aeroespacial
y después de dos años de prohibiciones
por la pandemia del cob y 19 esta semana
se celebra la pascua en diferentes
partes del mundo en algunos lugares se
centran en el arte en otros en el baile
o la comida una festividad ligada a
distintas religiones y que sus
feligreses agradecen poder festejar de
manera presencial el informes de juan
pabló lucumí
regresan las celebraciones de pascua de
manera presencial en el mundo aunque en
cada región el festejo es diferente
todos agradecen poder hacerlo nuevamente
después de dos años de prohibiciones por
la pandemia del cob y 19 hasta el
vaticano miles de personas llegan de
distintas partes del mundo para conocer
algunas de las grandes iglesias de roma
mientras que en lituania ciudades visten
sus árboles con huevos de colores una
tradicional costumbre que divierte a los
niños y que regresa como una actividad
familiar estos son huevos de gallinas
reales se sopló su contenido fueron
lavados y luego decorados con hilo
tejidos con brillo y distintos
materiales son obras de arte en las que
la gente pone mucho trabajo pasando
tiempo junto a sus hijos
mientras tanto entre bailes risas y
latigazos se celebra la semana santa en
el salvador
disfrazados los salvadoreños castigan a
los visitantes por los pecados que
cometieron durante el año una festividad
que se realiza en la semana en la que el
cristianismo recuerda la resurrección de
jesús y el 2021 y lo trasmitimos vía
facebook por nuestra página oficial
entonces nosotros hemos tratado de hacer
nuestra manera de que esto no se pierdan
y hoy pues por supuesto tenemos la
oportunidad nuevamente de volver a las
calles de texistepeque motivo de alegría
y como digo estamos doblemente motivados
para los judíos en la pascua se
conmemora la liberación del pueblo judío
de la esclavitud de egipto después de
dos años sin celebrar en comunidad los
judíos ortodoxos de la pascua presencial
como una oportunidad para vender el
tradicional pan sin levadura
un producto que para estas fechas se
produce y vende en grandes cantidades
debido a creencias y costumbres hebreas
y hasta aquí este repaso a las
principales noticias de la actualidad
internacional les invitamos a que sigan
con nosotros en france 24 y les
recordamos que pueden ampliar toda esta
hay mucha más información en nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]